hey this is really interesting our
friend mehdi hassan has a new show on
peacock peacock as i understand it is
a new streaming network offshoot of nbc
or msnbc it's it's nbc related one of
the nbc's
and metty interviewed former trump
national security adviser john bolton
now john bolton was also one of the
architects of the iraq war
i don't think john bolton knew what to
expect when he was interviewed by mehdi
i don't think he realized he was going
to be confronted brutally by maddie
hassan
it's really a pleasure to watch so let's
dig into a clip where
maddie hassan asking john bolton whether
he regrets
all the people that died as a result of
the iraq war
which bolton pushed and helped
orchestrate let's get into the first
clip
so let's talk about the the complex
issues you said you wanted to discuss
you say in your book
that unlike mike pompeo who had to
recant his support for the iraq war
during senate confirmation hearings you
didn't have to because you were not
confirmed by the senate as national
security adviser
and correct me if i'm wrong you don't
have any regrets you never have
apologized for the iraq war unlike a lot
of other former supporters of it like
joe biden
so what i'm wondering is all those
thousands of people who died in iraq all
of those innocent iraqi civilians men
women children
killed by us airstrikes some of them in
massacres at haditha mahmudiyah balad
none of those weigh on your conscience
none of those deaths ever keep you up at
night
you don't know what you're talking about
the iraq war
which was the period that lasted about
four weeks
and resulted in the overthrow of saddam
hussein
was a brilliant military victory by the
united states
and other coalition forces and that the
removal of saddam hussein from power was
the right idea at the time
and it's true today where the united
states
made a mistake and i've said this
repeatedly over the years
was in the period following the
overthrow of saddam hussein
i do not think we should have set up a
coalition provisional authority i think
we should have kept our troops in iraq
for a lot of reasons
but i think we should have turned
responsibility for the government over
to iraqis as soon as possible
you do not increase a people's political
maturity by making decisions for them
you increase their political maturity by
making them make decisions
for themselves so people talk about the
iraq wars though it started in 2003
and lasted until 2011 when obama
withdrew everybody
as if every single decision in that
eight-year period
followed inevitably unalterably from the
single decision to invade in 2003
and that's simply not right this is
super interesting because it's a really
cynical
way of looking at the war when john
bolton says listen
the war was four weeks it was a single
military operation and we won it
everything else that happened is not the
war it's other stuff and decisions made
by other people
this is like saying listen vietnam
itself didn't really cause that much
chaos
uh you know endless
numbers of veterans needing treatment
for life and political problems
it was really the management in the five
years that followed the vietnam war that
were the problem we can't really blame
the vietnam war for all of those
problems
well would any of that have been the
issue an issue if we didn't go into
vietnam in the first place so when john
bolton says it was a four-week thing
that went fine
as a military operation everything else
wasn't the iraq war
including all the troops and civilians
that died after the four weeks
it's laughable imagine a surgeon saying
listen
the brain surgery itself went fine i
mean
okay as a result the patient had three
years of complications and bad outcomes
but
that other doctors were dealing with
that the
surgery itself was fine any reasonable
person would say
these are the uh
complications that are part of the
package when you decide to do the
surgery you own the complications as
well
you hopefully understood
that the risks were understood and
necessary
given the reason you did the surgery but
you don't just walk away and say that's
somebody else's problem
let's watch a little more uh and mehdi
hassan actually makes this point to john
bolton
you say it's simply not right but the
reality is hundreds of thousands of
iraqis died there was torture
millions of refugees and that did follow
from the decision by george w bush dick
cheney and others in the administration
like yourself to invade iraq
hundreds of thousands of people died and
just to go back to my question which you
didn't answer
do those deaths never do those deaths
never weigh on your conscience was my
question which you didn't answer
no i did answer and i'll answer it again
since you didn't seem to listen to it
the the fact was after the overthrow of
saddam hussein
a number of decisions could have been
made in different ways i don't believe
in u.s participation in nation
i think nations have to build themselves
now this is just outrageous bolton
doesn't believe in us nation building
during the iraq war which bolton by the
way says was four weeks long
during the iraq war all these neocons
were talking about
spreading democracy to iraq uh and he
now says he doesn't believe in nation
building and he wasn't the guy involved
in those decisions
he knew what the bush administration
planned
to do and for him to now say well they
didn't
involve me in those decisions give me a
break
he believes in four weeks of military
and saying we're done
and now it's up to them and he has
nothing to do with it and it continues
in this
bizarre way and had the united states
followed through with that approach
rather than
engaging in extensive nation building
the outcome
i think could well have been very
different but delay
what happened in iraq on the single
decision to overthrow saddam hussein
is historically completely wrong but no
one's doing that they're pointing to the
war and the invasion and the occupation
you're trying to disconnect the
occupation
with respect john bolton you weren't you
weren't a pundit on fox news then you
were in government i don't remember you
quitting
in objection to the occupation and the
fact is that occupation
that occupation let me just finish my
question you come back in that
occupation produced
thousands of dead torture refugees uh
richard clark who was white house
counter-terrorism tsar at the time
uh shortly after 9 11 called war crimes
kofi annan called the war illegal i just
wonder do you ever worry that
you know people have tried to do
citizens arrests on you in the past do
you ever worry
you may have to face a court to answer
for that war on that occupation
for the war crimes that happened back
then uh of course not because what
you're saying is completely
ludicrous and those who made those kinds
of criticisms
are not reflecting what actually
happened
and i made clear in my first book
surrender is not an option
that i was largely excluded from actual
decision making
on iraq by colin powell because he felt
i had a different point of view than he
did
so my my observations here are from
somebody who
had a pretty good idea what was going on
inside
didn't agree with it but didn't have
much influence over policy i'm not
trying to duck the issue
but but you're making a grievous factual
error
when you attribute everything that came
after the overthrow of saddam
to the u.s decision to do that that's
called the post hoc ergo propter hawk
fallacy
look it up okay while i look it up let
me just ask you that question one more
time you keep saying i'm not listening
to you but i've asked twice i'll ask one
third time because i want to talk about
iran and the nuclear deal i know you
have strong views there
very quickly on iraq you have no regrets
about the thousands of iraqis who died
in iraq after the invasion they never
bother you never keep you up at night
never away on your conscience
i didn't say that at all and what i'm
saying is that the
the actual casualties and the overthrow
of saddam hussein
i understand that but you're still not
answering the question so i think you
get the picture there of how that all
went
not not well uh super interesting
and i've been watching clips of the
mehdi hassan show he's very good at this
and uh we are going to continue
following and seeing
uh what other interviews he lands but
this is very very interesting and it's
i encourage you to watch the full
interview because seeing john bolton
listen there's no denying john bolton is
an intelligent guy
and that john bolton is a very
articulate
um advocate for his completely
harebrained
neoconservative foreign policy that you
you can't watch and say this guy's an
idiot particularly
when you can compare him to the people
in power right now including donald
trump
um but he was not prepared to actually
defend
the morality of what he helped to
orchestrate because there it's
you're trying to defend the indefensible
quite frankly and that was very much
exposed during that interview
if you've been watching the show you've
probably heard me talk about how much i
love
my helix mattress well i was really
excited to hear that helix has launched
a new company called
all form which makes premium
customizable sofas and chairs
with the same level of quality and
comfort
that i expect from these guys and all
form is one of our sponsors today
they're giving you 20 percent off at
allforum.com
pacman they actually sent me a couch
which i put
in my living room at home it's now my
favorite piece of furniture
in the house it took me just minutes to
set it up it's
solidly built it's huge it's roomy
it has a modern minimalist design which
i love but it's also
very comfortable fabric is soft clearly
very high quality it has become the
focal point of my living room
their prices are very reasonable and
when you get a new sofa or chair
you get 100 days to decide if you want
to keep it and the best part is
everything comes with a lifetime
warranty
stop buying poorly made furniture go to
customize
your own all form sofa or chair right
now
and get 20 off your entire order when
you get there
by going to all dot com slash pacman
i've also put the link right underneath
this video